i am charlotte stigg co-founder and ceo
of handbag clinic today we're going to
be looking at mold removal on a handbag
this bag was actually at the back of a
wardrobe um and a pipe burst behind the
wardrobe which created the perfect area
for mold to be spawned
our artisan will always start by
assessing the type of mold that it is
and making sure it's safe for them to
work on from there we will use a range
of tools to begin scraping the kind of
bulk of that mold off
they will select the tool that will be
most successful in removing that but
also avoiding any scuffs or scratches to
that leather underneath
in some areas we can use a metal tool
because the leather is a little bit
harder wearing in those places
and the mold is less attached to the bag
we will go in with the wooden tool and
when we are getting a bit closer to that
leather because we obviously don't want
to scratch or damage that leather knee
and we then go in with a brush to remove
any excess
air that is bright in the top as well
once we have removed as much dry mold as
we possibly can we then will start with
the mold removal this bag was so heavily
saturated we needed to make sure we
killed the mold it was going all the way
through that skin
a leather skin is absorbent in the same
way that our skin is absorbent so we
needed to make sure we kill it all the
way through to make sure that wouldn't
come back at a later stage
the artisan will spray the mold removal
solution direct onto the bag this is
something that we do not recommend that
anybody tries at home any product going
on a leather should always go into a
cloth first usually because spraying
direct if you don't have the correct
training can lead to actually damaging
the leather further it's important that
a bag that's saturated with mold is
handled by professionals so that they
are able to really kill the base of that
mold to make sure it doesn't come back
spread to your other items in your
wardrobe and to make sure that the bag's
not damaged in the process as well
[Music]
once we've completed the mold removal
and killed the actual cause of the mold
we will then move on to cleaning the bag
to remove any additional chemicals and
to hygienically clean the bag getting it
ready to be returned to its client the
artisan is now applying our specialist
in-house cleaner this removes any
additional chemicals that are left on
the bag
making sure that we've hygienically
cleaned the bag throughout as well we
are turning our leather cleaner into a
foam
this it just gives a very even coating
throughout the item it also creates and
really nice lava to make sure it really
gets into all of the skin
and cleans it thoroughly this bag has
already been through so much cleaning by
this point so we are simply just wiping
away any of those excess chemicals and
excess dirt on the bag
once this process is complete this item
is ready to go back to the client this
client had huge sentimental attachment
to this bag really loved it and didn't
think it was savable and because we
managed to save it when they got it back
they actually rang our office and were
crying with happiness down the phone
that would save their bag with the
cleaning process mold is tricky because
you've got to make sure you kill those
enzymes that are creating the mold so
they do need very different products
even if a bag has a small amount of mold
it's important that you seek help from a
professional because you need to kill
the sauce if you don't kill the sauce it
will just spread back throughout that
handbag it also may spread other items
in your wardrobe